so
i want to start off uh do a little
warm-up
um so
yeah here we go here we go some exercise
warm-ups all right
my shadow's blocking okay can anybody
else uh
let's see anybody out in the crowd
you're too far away
all right let's just get started all
right
so let's shut this guy down
and we'll start my little node process
here
and get to some slides so this is my
favorite part of the thing so uh
run right over hey we're sweating to the
web
we come right in so yeah this is called
sweating to the web
because we're gonna we're gonna move
around we're gonna move our bodies to
the web
my name is ben farrell you can catch me
on twitter at be farrell forever
so it's i'm having a fun time with all
this stuff so let's let's get going so
about me
i hey
um so yeah uh i like to call myself a
creative developer
um i like uh oh i just got why you were
clapping thank you
the gestures yes that was i've been
practicing these to make sure they went
okay and yes thanks for the applause
uh but i like doing like fun interactive
experiences games
i like whatever whatever happens happens
and sometimes that happens
hello so i like doing fun uh games and
different interactive experiences
and uh there we go
this happens when you're up on stage so
uh
and uh so what i wanted to get started
with is in the 80s we were all
sitting on the couch this is the typical
scene from the 80s
sitting around eating snacks being
generally like
kind of fat and lazy so yeah we were we
were really lazy
this only happens when i'm on stage so
here's another picture al bundy
he's really lazy uh again
80 typical 80s stuff uh just being lazy
sitting on the couch eating snacks
no good
you saw it happen i did it um
so but then something awesome happened
uh
so tv has always been a sit-down medium
since the 1950s when it was just kicking
off
and the obesity crisis was just getting
started in the 80s
you know my parents were like no snack
food no junk food
we're gonna ration your tv time you
can't watch duck tales you can't watch
uh you know batman and stuff but uh
and you know it was largely blamed on tv
and snacks so what happened that was so
awesome it was the 80s fitness craze and
we had we had this tv
they'd been inactive since the 1950s
richard simmons he transformed it we
took this inactive medium
i wish i could gesture this sucks so
instead of sitting on the couch richard
simmons and friends like jane fonda and
people
they got us to clear a space on our
living room floor and we did some cardio
so we took this
inactive medium and we we changed the
way we watch tv for the better
but at the same time we had uh we had a
nintendo taken off nintendo wasn't the
first game console but
you know nintendo popularized it with
mario and everybody
so we had that medium taken off but
guess what it wasn't any better
gamers you know you were sitting in
front of that thing and
you hit a tv and like using your
consoles reaching into the bag of chips
it wasn't it wasn't any better but maybe
it was
because hello
um nintendo came out with a power pad in
1986.
it wasn't that popular at the time but
it got you it put the buttons on the
floor and let you dance around a bit
and got you moving by just placing those
buttons in different locations so that
was great
how is it thank you now it's finally
working all right
dance dance revolution
guys this isn't funny
dance dance revolution 1998 it really
took off
uh the the game pads on the on the floor
so it was it was really taking off
japan got a 1998 first
really really popularized this because
we had we had music and we had dance
unlike nintendo's 8-bit days when we had
like really weird characters moving
around
um but you know at heart game
controllers they were just
funny looking things with buttons that
were displayed so i mean you think of a
guitar hero the buttons are just on the
fretboard
they're the same controller buttons
we've already had same with dance dance
revolution they're just displaced
i won't lie to you it's incredibly fun
using these things they were awesome to
play
and the the experiences we had were just
they were just fun
so you know nintendo you know they they
took this and kicked it up a notch so we
have
an accelerometer built in so you know i
can i can tell
the orientation of where i'm putting the
controller and i had an infrared
optical sensor so i can point to the tv
and like figure out where it is on the
screen
it also had the button smashing buttons
and directional pads so i could still
play my same games
um and you could move around a little
bit so we're getting there wireless
connected
via bluetooth no wires anymore awesome
always try and i always fail it only
works when i don't want it to work
um so then sony came along and guess
what they had the eye and eye toy for
ps2 and ps3 so
they took these cameras um they're just
normal web cameras
they don't do anything fancy but they
hooked them up
uh and they did some computer vision
stuff
i'm not that familiar with computer
vision stuff but you know they had edge
detection
face detection pixel tracking head
tracking
um and they also had a four array
directional microphone
or a four array microphone so not just
having like four microphones
you could tell hey a user's over here or
yours is over here or
you could cancel out some echoes around
the room and you could
get rid of background noise so
everything was a lot more clear with
four microphones with different sound
sources coming in
and then you know the problem with web
cameras is
living rooms can get dark where we're
playing can get dark and
you know there might be weird lights all
over the place that shine up and
cause lighting to be weird um and uh
so what's what sony did was they put led
balls
um they put them on the tip of the
controller and
uh they lit up a different color for
every player and the size and the
position
it still uses computer vision with a
simple web camera
but they give distance in motion and
they they you know better where they are
especially in a dark room and they also
built in accelerometer just like the wii
for uh you know rotation and improved
motion data on that controller so
things got better they're starting to
get more active
all is cool now microsoft
they came onto the scene so they have
the typical rgb camera they have the
typical
four array microphone but what they have
is
what they added to it is a infrared
depth-finding camera
so let's look at that a little bit
but i digress because we're talking
about consoles here we're all web
developers
um so let's think about this a little
bit
um connect i think it was in 2010 they
came out with the the connect for
windows sdk
and they support the application
development c sharp blah blah blah
there's bindings for so what they could
there's this project on the scene called
connect.js it was pretty cool
um it created a flash and air websocket
server
and sent all that web data over to
javascript through a websocket
and that's how connect.js works so
that's a cool project and i tried it out
it was it was a good time
um the official the official official
windows sdk
it costs 200 250 um
but the not so official kit it you can
get one for a hundred dollars or under
um and that's where that's what i call
poor man's connect hacking so
you can get a xbox connect and i found
one online for like 70 bucks used
um and you have to get a 10 usb splitter
for the power supply so you're
connecting with usb you're connecting
with a power
ac adapter the windows sdk works great
on this
it's not legal for commercial use though
so that's that's the thing that's how
microsoft gets you on this
and they also lack the firmware to give
you a proper near mode so if you get
really close to the camera
it's not going to necessarily work
properly
but again i digress because we're web
developers right
so how can we how can we get around this
no microsoft or maybe some microsoft i
don't mind microsoft but i'd rather not
be all
microsoft um so open source
awesome open source library for 3d
sensing uh open on eye foundation
they call themselves the standard
framework for 3d sensing they are
cross-platform so
ubuntu uh you know linux osx windows
it also works with the connect but that
that scenario is windows only
unfortunately
however if you get a camera like i have
this small guy right here
um that's an uh that's an asus um
it works with those other cameras i'm
running this on ubuntu it works on osx
works on windows
cross-platform cross-platform goodness
it's awesome
um so like i said asus x-john pro live
is what i have
there's also the the prime sense carmine
and prime sense was the original people
that came up with this technology
license it over microsoft for the
original connect
so you can get those for 119 to 200 it's
smaller than the connect
no motor so like the the connect has a
motor and it can follow you around the
room really creepily
and uh no extra power supply is needed
i'm not plugged in via an ac adapter
here i just plug right in usb in my
computer
all as well some of these some of these
guys don't have microphones
you can use your own sound setup that's
fine
yay working again so uh not so
open source oh did i skip a slide no i
didn't okay
so uh there was open ni and that gave
you a cool
depth finding data 19 minutes all right
exactly what i have um
not so open source so there was uh the
open and i stuff
that gave you depth depth data so like
how far
everything is close to the screen um but
we got some middleware and a lot of
people are making middleware for this
one of those people is prime sense so
they're trying to they're trying to get
this out there
and uh they give you skeletal tracking
user detection
and a few gestures so that's that's cool
however um you know it's all
still c plus plus but let's take a look
at what these cameras do first so
if you're we're talking about a normal
web camera you know playstation i
um they'll typically use edge detection
so if you go into photoshop you can take
a look at
uh you can use edge detection on a photo
and you can get the edges and that's
kind of how these
to my understanding that's kind of how
these places you know they'll they'll
do gestures and object tracking and
whatnot they'll get the edges and work
from there
so
but an rgb plus d camera depth being
depth
um they'll they'll get uh they'll get
all the depth data so the the lighter
stuff
is the closer to you the the darker
stuff is farther away
and you know behind the scenes if you
put on infrared goggles
you could see tons of beams shooting out
at people and
that's how they the the beams will shoot
out at somebody or an object in the
background
bounce back to you and uh that's how
they see and that's why
that's why like in this slide you know
it's not very fine-tuned
it's kind of sketchy it's kind of blurry
um so that's that's that's what's going
on there because
these aren't very small infrared beams
so they're not they're not very
fine-tuned for performance here
but it still works because you can
interpret that depth stream
get you know my hand is over here my
hand is over here um
my torso is over here so you can get
full skeleton control for this
but again i have to digress because
we're talking about c plus plus
um and yeah we'd probably rather be
stuck on g sharp on windows
but luckily i can make a plug-in for
this and i made a node.js plugin so
hopefully now we can get crack and sweat
into the web so
it's actually on mpm npm install new
emotion i have it on github right here
so my point in here is not to sell
anything or anything like take it learn
from it
break it apart fork it whatever you got
to do i just want to see cool
experiences
um on the on the web using browsers and
uh node.js
so an example of what we can see here is
you know i can i can go in and start a
start a skeleton listener so i add a
left hand a right hand
i add a callback at a certain interval
50 milliseconds being my default
and i can take a look at okay in my
callback function i'm getting a
parameter
my skeleton i get x y z coordinates for
any joint i want x y z rotation for any
joint i want
my my hand being 100 extended being not
extended at all
um so this is the kind of things you can
get if you look look at the skeleton so
i you know it's it's it's fun stuff it's
really fun stuff
um and event listening i can i can see
oh is my user out of the scene
or if it would do that
there we go all right so yeah when my
user's out of scene when it stopped
tracking when it start tracking
all that good stuff and i can listen for
gestures too so
swiping down up left right i can figure
out a wave on my hand
um and uh yeah so
you can write i'm writing my own
gestures and some sometimes they're not
very good especially in situations like
this when
things are going crazy but um i like the
i like the skeleton
uh stuff myself the best um and uses
it's it's a cool it's really fun to use
um
and other than that you can create cool
10-foot interfaces so like the xbox
uh you're sitting on your living room
couch and you're controlling an
interface with your hands
um there's also innovative games using
your whole body to
uh to get out and make a game
interacting with public spaces how many
ti
you know there's so many touch screens
out there and
they all get smudged up and greasy what
if you could create some public space
uh interactive experience where you
don't have to you know touch a screen
you just use your hands in thin air
real world analytics this is a cool uh
thing that somebody did
a cool application so there's a company
called shop reception
shop reception i would have never
thought of this they
mount like a couple connects or whatever
whatever cameras
on top of a shopping aisle and they look
down on people
and they gather real-time metrics on
when people take
stuff from the aisle stuff from the the
shopping display
and they'll get heat maps they'll get
analytics data so this is something i
would have never thought of
and people are doing it with these
cameras so it's like a real life
google analytics for you
but here's what i don't want to do and
uh there's a book called brave newy
world and
it's about the only we're talking about
natural user interfaces and natural user
interfaces are the type of thing where
you're interacting with something very
naturally not using a mouse and clicking
around
just walk up to something and figure out
how to use it um and they i stole this
from their book
um they made a great little point so
we all wanted power gloves back in the
80s when we were kids at least i did i
don't did anybody have one
yeah like two people so uh
and why was that i mean i i don't think
my parents don't wanted me to buy one
but
um the reason they were a failure was
there was like two power glove games
ever made they could also be played with
a standard controller
therefore you know you didn't see any
user experience innovation on these
games it was just an awkward controller
you use it looked so cool
but at the same time what are you
getting out of it kind of nothing so
the author of this book kind of says you
know why bother with this when you can
when you can try other things and you
know i
kind of put the connection in my brain
to kinesis io
kinesis io is a project uh started last
fall or summer and they came up with
this cool thing with the connect and
you could take div tags and mark them up
with special css styles
and or and you know mark them up as
interactive
and what it would do is go through your
dom and look for these things and say
hey this is interactive this is gonna
i'm gonna make it
i can click by putting my hand up in the
air and holding it there for a while so
that's how i click links
i can scroll around on the screen i can
use a cursor
so all cool stuff when you think about
it
but if you really think about it why
bother because
we already know how to interact with a
web page and this is kind of an awkward
way of doing it
um i don't mean to be disparaging of
these guys but
you know maybe we could create better
experiences
with with these new natural user
interface tools we have the hardware
so um so that's that's my why bother
um so like i said we're talking about
natural user interfaces
they should to reiterate they should
really be intuitive
we're talking about gestures we're
talking about motion we're talking about
speech
2d gestures are already on all your
mobile devices you can pinch
zoom flip photos um and guess what
speech is also a form of natural user
interaction we're talking to our devices
now um so we're talking to uh
google now where we're talking to siri
um
and so some rules
people are already doing this stuff
especially on xbox and
microsoft is already coming up with some
rules for this so they're
one of those rules for games use the
game mindset
in games you know people like being
challenged they like they don't mind
looking a little silly like i'm
doing with all this stuff
so and they're eager to learn they're
eager to improve um
but for applications if if i'm using a
slide deck for example
i gotta walk right up there i gotta
start using it right away i don't want
any guidance
no learning curve i want my app to be
immediately functional or people will
just
not want it
and i have some gesture guidelines as
going along here so
what you want to do is create a good
balance of intuitive and intentional so
when i say intuitive i mean i like i
said i want to walk
right up to something i want to start
using it i want to i want to know what's
going on
and intentional means you know my
gestures haven't been working out well
with you guys here
but you know i don't want to do anything
accidental like i have been doing here
with you guys so if i
start getting really excited about all
this stuff i don't want my stuff to go
off
and advance the slide so you gotta
strike a good balance there between with
your gestures
and i want to see gesture progress so
when i raise my hand here
you can see the my gesture starting to
start
and then i can see it cancel so i have
some good visual feedback there what are
my arms getting raised when i'm ready to
go
and do a gesture so i have some progress
steps in there in my plug-in
so yeah i'm hoping you guys
try it for yourself like i said you know
take apart my plug-in learn from it
whatever you want to do um websockets
are probably the most obvious way to use
this technology
um so what i have is a a a plug-in
for node the nui motion plug-in and what
it does is just connects over web
sockets and sends mo
and sends data to the browser and like
this guy is a reveal js
obviously and i have a i have a plug-in
going in reveal.js to pick up this data
and listen for gestures
um but the another cool thing i found
was
making a desktop application with app.js
or node webkit so node webkit takes um
it it takes your uh your node project
and
slaps a webkit front end on it and
bundles it all up on one project and i
tried that with this and it works great
um so check out node webkit i have some
links at the end for this
and then you know the other reason i
want to check this out is because
open ni the foundation they're a little
biased of course but they project a 15
billion dollar 3d sensing in
industry by 2018. it's a little far in
the future but
i like to get in on the ground floor and
stuff like this so um and start playing
with stuff because just because it's fun
um and prime sense the company that
makes
um some of these sensors they're being
sold in bulk to device manufacturers so
um you'll see just about to see them in
smart tvs you'll start to see them in uh
smartphones all over the place so
i think it i think it's a cool uh a cool
thing to try as web developers to
get out there and start even if you know
my
who cares but if we can start
experimenting with ways to
do this stuff on the web and start
experimenting with innovative ways to um
get all this stuff going and i think i
think we can get a jump start on this so
yeah so
here's some links um you can find my
manifesto on all this stuff on
sweatintotheweb.com
um here's my uh my uh github repository
um and then my website and then uh
node webkit which i mentioned for
wrapping all your apps up
as a whole package um so yeah that's my
presentation but i wanted to show you
guys a quick little demo
um that will traditionally work better
than this one
and i think like you know everybody i
talk to when they do stuff like this
they're all over the painting demos so i
made a i made a little painting demo
um let's see
and i also let me switch it over to
https because i wanted to use
google google chrome 25 they have a web
speech web speech kit api in there
um so if we switch it over to https it
can always be on and
always be listening to you so let's see
if it can hear me i hope it can
maybe the micros are weird but so we're
gonna um
so i have some uh my painting in here so
if i keep my hand in like this it's not
painting but
when you reach out your hand which i
think is a good uh
nice way of telling it you want to
actually do something
it starts painting and so we can paint
along
and then we can start erasing things and
you know like i said like bring your
hand in and it doesn't do it anymore
you're just
going around the screen with your icon
so we can start painting
and you know if i shout at this thing so
let me hide the mic give me a purple
paintbrush
i think the sound is weird on that one
but so yeah that's
that that's one thing you can try to do
with the skeleton data
um since i have a few minutes let me
show you uh let me show you guys
another little demo here
oh
so here's a little demo where you start
out as an egg and then when you uh
get on screen it should hatch
let me refresh
there we go starting to hatch come on
pick me up
oh no okay there we go so
magically it hatched i know you guys you
know you didn't see it or anything but
let me let me
yeah okay we're back to an egg so when
you go in front of the screen again
oh come on seriously
let me start let me start that uh oh
jesus
only happens when i'm up in front of you
guys
all right come on there we go so the the
interaction mechanism here
is we're seeing the rotation of each arm
and we're controlling the the bird's arm
was that
and um the the physics on this are
really wacky enough to tweak it but
you can start flying away
if i get high enough
i can start floating down and i think my
computer just died
that was that was really rough so i'm
gonna have to put on my extra sweat band
here
thanks guys much appreciated
you